i was obsessed with the question and
still am
i will never be i will never
quench my thirst for russian history
i love that period of
1890 to 1925.
it's just like it's so [ __ ] crazy
like the autocracy embodied in
zara alexander and then you get this
like weird fail son
nicholas who is kind of a good guy
but also terrible and also russian
autocracy itself is terrible
and then i just became obsessed with the
question of like why did the bolshevik
revolution succeed
because like people in russia didn't
necessarily want bolshevism
people suffered a lot under bolshevism
and it led to stalinism
how did vladimir lenin do it right like
and i became obsessed with that question
and it's still
i find it so interesting which is that
series
of accidents of history incredible
boldness by lenin
incredible real politic smart
unpopular decisions made by trotsky and
stalin
and just like the arrogance of the czars
and of the of the russian
like autocracy and just but at the same
time there's all these like cultural
implications of this right in terms of
like how it became hollowed out
post catherine the great and all that i
was obsessed with
talk because russia was an actual
autocracy
and like actually and i'm like it was
there like they didn't even
remove serfdom to like the civil war in
america like that's
crazy like you know and nobody really
talks about it
and i just yeah i was like was
bolshevism
a natural reaction to the excesses of
tsarism there is a convenient
explanation where that is true
but there were also a series of
decisions made by lenin and stalin
to kill many of the people in the center
left and marginalized them
to and also not to associate with the
more
quote unquote like like amenable
communists
in order to make sure that their pure
strain of bolshevism
was the only thing and the reason i like
that is because it comes back to a point
i made it
earlier it's all about intentionality
which is that you actually
can will something into existence yes
even if people don't want it
that was the craziest thing like nobody
wanted this yeah but it still ruled for
half a century well more actually i mean
almost you know that's seven
years to think that there could have
been a history
of uh the soviet union
that was dramatically different than
uh leninism stalinism that
was completely different like almost
would be the american story
yeah oh easily i mean there's a world
where and i don't have all the
characters there's like karensky and
then there was like
whoever lenin's number two stalin's
chief rival and even i mean look even a
soviet union led by trotsky that's a
whole other world
right like literally a whole other world
and
yeah it's just i don't know i find it so
interesting i will never not be
fascinated by russia
i always will it's funny that i get to
talk to you because it's like
i read this book i forget what it's
called it won i think it won a paul
surprise
and it was like the story of i tried to
understand russia post
crimea because i i came up amongst
people who are much more like
neoconservative and they're like [ __ ]
russia you know russia
bad bye and i was like okay like what do
these people think
and we have this narrative of like the
fall of the soviet union and then i read
this book from the perspective of
russians who lived through the fall and
they were like this i was like this is
terrible
like actually the introduction of
capitalism was awful
and all like the rise of all these crazy
oligarchs
that's why putin was came to power to
like restore um restore
order to the oligarchy and he still
talks to this day do you guys i mean
that's always the threat of like do you
want to return to the 90s
right do you want to return to yeltsin
yeah and like but the thing is in the
west
we have this like our own propaganda of
like no yeltsin was great that was the
golden age what could have been
with russia and i was like well what do
actual russians think
and so that yeah i i i'll always be
fascinated by it and then just
like to understand the idea of feeling
encircled by nato
and all that you have to understand like
russian defense
theory all the way up going back to the
tsars has always been
defense in depth in terms of having
estonia lithuania and more as like
protection of the heartland i'm not
justifying in this so nato shills like
please don't come after me
but and look estonian estonians like
nato they want to be in nato so i don't
want to minimize that i'm more just
saying like
i understand him and russia much better
having done that and we are very
incapable in america i think this is
probably because my parents are
immigrants i've traveled a lot
of putting yourself in the mind of
people
who aren't western and haven't lived a
history
especially our lives of america's
[ __ ] awesome we're the number one
country in the world like yeah i'm like
we're literally better than you
like in many ways and they
they can't empathize with people who
have suffered so much
yeah and i just yeah it's just so
interesting to me
you